Speaker 1: So we've talked before about how
different social media networks seem to appeal
to a particular demographic groups and seem
to be responsible for the spread of different
types of disinformation and propaganda.
One thing we know about Facebook specifically
is that in the 2016 election, with regard
to Hillary versus Trump type propaganda and
fake news and during 20 20, with regard to
the pandemic, anti VAX propaganda, et cetera,
Facebook was a really big player and factor
in the disinformation and fake news and propaganda
that was read, believed and signal boosted
by older Americans.
And indeed, for some period of time now, Donald
Trump has been banned from Twitter as well
as Facebook and other platforms.
We will know tomorrow whether Donald Trump
will be allowed back on Facebook.
And I know that it may seem in some sense
trivial, but because we know I mean, listen,
Trump followers fell for the grift of donating
to fight the election results to the tune
of, what was it, 60 something, 70 something
million dollars, in part because of the campaigns
on platforms like Facebook.
And indeed, the Facebook oversight board has
reportedly already decided, but will be announcing
tomorrow morning whether Donald Trump, Donald
Trump's Facebook account will be reinstated.
There was this idea previously that adits,
because of what Facebook said when they banned
Trump, it was an indefinite suspension because
of the risk of allowing Trump to continue
on the platform in terms of violence and in
terms of incitement, but that the language
was about the right now in the aftermath of
the January 6th riots, in fact, on January
7th, but that it would be revisited in the
future.
And indeed, that revisitation has taken place
place.
And we are going to know tomorrow the impact
of this could be huge because Donald Trump
has been relegated to putting out these written
statements on presidential former presidential
letterhead.
They read like tweets, without a doubt, but
he has not had that core audience to share
them.
You sort of need to go and find them or you
need to be following certain accounts that
are signal boosting them.
If Donald Trump is indeed back on Facebook,
this is going to reopen the door to all sorts
of weaponized disinformation and propaganda.
It could play a role in the 2022 election,
given Donald Trump's clear desire to be a
sort of kingmaker and to see the people he
supports win in 2022.
So this is not a trivial decision.
It has reportedly already been made.
And you can be absolutely sure that if Donald
Trump is allowed back on Facebook, it's also
going to put some pressure on other social
media platforms to allow Donald Trump back
on.
Because, listen, I'm the first to admit.
It's unusual that a former president is banned
from all of these platforms, I don't think
it's a free speech issue.
Every single one of these platforms, as I've
talked about before, has every legal right
to say violations of our terms of service
are going to be met with consequences, regardless
of whether it's a former president or not.
But it's so Trump is so unusual in how he
used these platforms to spread this disinformation.
And we now find ourselves in a really weird
situation where the former president is not
able to use these platforms.
So the pressure, if Facebook says Trump's
coming back on for Twitter and YouTube and
whoever else to say, we're also letting Trump
back on, the danger has passed, so to speak,
is going to be significant.
So we'll see what that decision is that's
made tomorrow will, of course, very quickly,
I think, see what use Donald Trump plans to
make of these platforms.
And although in the aftermath of these bans,
Donald Trump has said he's happy not being
on them, things are better or he's, you know,
whatever.
I think it's abundantly clear that if given
the opportunity, he will immediately start
making use of
those platforms.